you see mystery is an intellectual
process
but suspense is essentially
an emotional process only
things that are creative
and not destructive i think
hatred is wasted energy
i don't give a damn about what the film
is about
i'm more interested in how to handle the
material
to create an emotion in an audience
so these people have paid money to be
scared just as much as they go to
disneyland
and go on the big dip or whatever they
call that railway
you can have an original idea you can
have just
a couple of sentences and from that
the film begins
four people are sitting around the table
talking about baseball whatever you like
five minutes of it very dull
suddenly a bomb goes up
blows the people to smooth what do the
audience have
10 seconds of shock
now take the same scene and
tell the audience there is a bomb under
that table
and will go off in five minutes
but the whole emotion of the audience is
totally different
because you've given them that
information that in five minutes time
that bomb will go off now
the conversation about baseball becomes
very vital
because they're saying to you don't be
ridiculous stop talking about
baseball there's a bomb under there
you've got the audience
working now the only difference
is although i've been guilty of
in the picture sabotage of making this
arab and i've never made it since
the bomb must never go off
because if you do you work that audience
into a state
and then they'll get angry because you
haven't provided them
with any relief and that's almost a must
so a foot touches the bomb somebody
looks down says my god
bomb out of the window then it goes on
just in time you once said that uh you
like to make an audience
scream through technical means what is
it about an audience screaming that you
like
how many times have you heard a woman
say oh i went to see
the movie and had a good cry
that's true they do you know what is a
good cry she never says i
went there and had a bad cry
otherwise she wouldn't have paid the
money to go in the first place
so these people have paid money to be uh
scared just as much as they go to
disneyland
and go on the big dip or whatever they
call that railway you know
the roller coaster oh yes because all
the haunted house
they pay to be scared if anybody goes on
a roller coaster
they scream it goes down the big
dip and up and around they're screaming
all the time
but always get off giggling yeah
or you go to the midway and you pay
money to go into the haunted house
and skeletons jump up and the floor
does all kinds of things but they always
come out
giggling now the question why do people
pay money to be scared
do you know the answer of course not
i earned my living doing it i have to
devote
a certain amount of footage in the
introduction to the characters
some piece of action that would be
interesting to look at rather than
just uh this is john smith this is his
wife
this is the sun in other words it's
it's like all exposition
it's a pill that has to be sugar-coated
in other words you are telling the
audience
giving them some information but at the
time you give it
it must appear to be something else
one other point i wanted to get into was
the technique you've
um developed from the facts i've
exploited through the years
sort of reaching past your actors and
literally directing the audience so that
you get the emotions you want not by the
players on screen
but by the you know by the people
sitting in the audience
which of course is what what any good
director should do but of course you've
made rather
a specialty or that's what it's all
about when
when did you sort of become conscious of
the fact that this is the way you would
uh
really specialize in directions during
my american period
i was became very conscious of audience
and uh well there are hints in the
beginning because the the the
closer example of the glass of drugged
wine
in the lady vanishes a very good example
of directing the audience to that and
not to the players
that is true well you see that comes
under the heading of avoiding the cliche
you see in the the poisoned wine
situation or the drugged wine
the character usually picks it up and
goes like that
oh by the way and you said this and he
does this about half a dozen times
which is such a cliche so i decided
to avoid that cliche and really leave
the wine there
untouched until the last minute but in
order to keep the audience reminded of
it
i photographed the scene part of the
scene through the two glasses
so that will keep the audience saying
well when are they going to pick up the
drug why
uh actually the
um central figure who is shall we say
being attacked or on the run if he's a
familiar figure
average man and also a familiar star
the story values are increased
accordingly
in other words if you walk along the
street and you see a street accident
and a man's lying there you say poor
fellow knocked down by an
automobile take a second looking at your
brother
look at the difference in the emotions
and that's why not only the
identification
but the but the quality of
identification
also matters and is a contributory thing
you see the uh i make many many
different kinds of pictures
and uh it would depend uh
you know what comes along i have no
particular
reference to be quite honest content
i'm not interested in at all i don't
give a damn about what the film is about
i'm more interested in how to handle the
material
to create an emotion in an audience
it's like uh you know it would be like
if one were painting a still
life i find you know so many people are
interested in the content
that if you painted the still life of
some apples on a plate
it'd be worrying whether the apples are
sweet or sour
who cares i don't care myself you know
many
you see many films there's a great
confusion
especially in my particular general work
there's a great confusion between the
words
mystery and suspense
and the two things are absolutely
miles apart you see mystery
is an intellectual process like in a
whodunit
but suspense is essentially
an emotional process
therefore you can only
get the suspense element going
by giving the audience information
and i just say you see many films which
have mysterious goings on you don't know
what's going
why the man is doing this why that and
you're about a third of the way through
the film before you realize
what it's all about and to me that's
completely wasted footage
because there's no emotion to it now the
third way
is what one might call pure
cinematics the assembly of
of film and how
it can be changed to create a different
idea now we have a close-up let me show
what he sees
let's assume he saw a woman
holding a baby in her arms now we cut
back
to his reaction to what he sees and he
smiles
now what is he as a character he's a
kindly man he's sympathetic
now let's take the middle piece of film
away the woman with the child
but leave his two pieces of film as they
were
now we'll put in a piece of film
of a girl in a bikini
he looks girl in a bikini
he smiles what is he now the dirty old
man
he's no longer the benign gentleman
who loves babies that's the difference
that's what film
can do for you i'm fascinated by writers
diaries by writers notebooks and
therefore as a fellow director
i'm fascinated at the point where you
feel yourself committed
is it in the script is it the first day
is it long before the script
where do you think it all starts for you
well uh for me it all starts with the
basic material first
now the question when you have we'll say
basic material
you may have a novel you may have a play
you can have an original idea you can
have just
a couple of sentences and from that
the film begins mr hitchcock what is
your definition of happiness
a clear horizon nothing to worry about
on your plate only things
that are creative and not destructive
when that's within yourself within me
i can't be a quarrelling i can't
bear feelings between people i think
hatred
is wasted energy
and it's all non-productive
some very sensitive a sharp
word said by say a person who has a
temper
uh if they're close to me
hurts me for days i know we're only
human
we do go in for these uh various
emotions
call them negative emotions
but when all these are removed and you
can look
forward road is clear ahead
and now you're going to create something
i think that's as happy as i would ever
want to be
you